là tous les jours les à différents logos
différents design et c'est celle qui
m'intéresse dans les produits à l'âge de
14 ans j'ai appris la broderie en gt1
pakistan et c'est là bas que j'ai et la
formation de deux ans de boudry et
ensuite j'étais allé à kaboul pour
travailler
c'est un payeur j'ai fais et des
vêtements traditionnels en bois
nous après j'étais allé pour travailler
c
base militaire pour les amériques je
faisais des cuissons pour l'uniforme
c'est pour s'ajouter à presse de
dangereux de tables rondes et manage
tout plein de problèmes comment après
[Applaudissements]
2016 mon patron m'a accepté pour nous
donner la stasi ici et quand j'ai
commencé à travailler ici j'ai montré
moi même comment je travaille
qu'est ce qu'ils étaient quand vous
utilisez les nazis ou aux profs pas trop
il était trop satisfait de moi et après
des stages il m'a donné directement
contre pour avoir régulier mais papier
aussi mais beaucoup pour une démarche
son problème à lui c'était sont sans
papiers on peut pas avoir de travail et
son travail on peut pas avoir de papiers
heureusement il ya une possibilité
effectivement c'est de pouvoir embaucher
quelqu'un effectivement c'est à la
limite limite de la légalité en fait
nous en fait il était déclaré
donc ils paient des cotisations à
l'urssaf et autres grâce au fait qu'il
avait un numéro sécurité sociale il
appelait déclaré il a travaillé il a
représenté un dossier est effectivement
il a pu régulariser ses papiers et en
fait je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
est parfaitement bien intégré en france
et qui méritent de
de pouvoir travailler en france en fait
moi je préfère investir sur quelqu'un
sur le long terme que trouver quelqu'un
qui reste trois mois qui j'apprends à
travailler qu'il repart genre forme un
autre lui je sentais qu'il était il
était là pour rester pour durer en fait
que j'ai écrit mon fils
de mon pays kaboul bas pour montrer pour
leur montrer que que j'ai fait hier 12
vinet
et pour montrer c'est pour ça j'ai brodé
sont ensuite c'est pour leur montrer que
vous venez
pourquoi je portais pourquoi je vendais
parce qu'ils l'aiment kaboul
j'ai repris le vert parce que je t'aime
des couleurs qui assurent le sur le
drapeau et puis je trouvais que c'était
assez un peu lumineux un peu joyeux
quand même parce que ça représente ce
moment là tout était plutôt ctp
collation de la journée ces brosses ça
fait comme une petite poche ouais du
coup oui c'est juste un morceau de blé
tous deux prennent ça c'est vous qui
voyez que des procédés parce que souvent
on va avoir l'occasion de raconter
oui l'histoire par exemple d'une marque
ou ses codes
mais là c'est vraiment raconter une
mémoire un peu pantois
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
mémoire en même temps faut que ça se
voit qu'on voit ça permet à eux aussi de
se sentir valorisé et fiers et peut-être
de relais de s'investir dans la vie
d'une manière différente que que si on
les traitait toujours comme des
personnes inférieur le boxeur très beau
c'est il m'a donné mes départs et paula
expérience à vivre le pire et la belette
et les marques et l'adresse chercheurs
mois vient d'alternance chercher moi est
long il a mené chez lui comme chez lui
d'ici là il est élu maire pour pas il
m'a posée qu'est ce que tu as rendu en
angleterre qui sous tend la main il m'a
ouvert la marque rm balises il